[Music]
Business News submitted by best actor of
2018 who's that gonna be a beauty salon
owner threatens a woman who gave her a
bad review what is that bad review and
is it well-deserved how do you get so
[ __ ] and little in that chair you get
so [ __ ] comfortable he's a big dude I
likes being small sometimes it makes me
feel like I'm being protected by
somebody else that's bigger who had
pizza for lunch like getting hugs by her
older brother he makes me feel safe so
this story takes place in New York get a
womb the Yelp reviewer her name is
Jessica New York close okay it's not an
Indian hairstylist it's in New York okay
all the images in your mind's just yeah
Shh I love the Indian [ __ ] Barbara
haircuts - [ __ ] - or they give you a
head massage and they [ __ ] just say
is that real huh is that real no I'd
like watching the minute it see to me it
looks relaxing but it's they literally
go legal have you seen the tide slapping
uh-uh
so you go in there and the lady all she
does so I guess it's like a health
Beauty type stimulate the [ __ ]
beating this she's gone everything that
I burn therapy sure - yeah no wait not
therapy but I felt like I should all
finally [ __ ] put on the skin and it
goes out or something huh yeah I rather
do that than the [ __ ] face laughing I
know Chinese have like the glow jar
things that solution that's like
hipsters like that stuff not that uh the
cupping yeah yeah that's that's why
people should know they took it away
from the Chinese yeah they did
that's not we had a [ __ ] gold one-up
it now we just punch each other in the
eyes black eyes feel better
I know you love a headache so this story
is like a whole bunch of drama between
the Yelp reviewer and then the brow
Asher sent ya a technician
so the initial yelp review was a
one-star there's what it says Jessica
wrote this the girl is beyond rude she
uses wax most high-level brow
specialists only tweeze and trim I work
in the beauty business and I was taken
back with her bizarre behavior
uncomfortable and borderline abusive
don't go here I will never return she is
a bully who does browse fYI don't show
up early she will tell you to get lost
until your exact time of your
appointment girl buy too many great brow
specialists in New York City your
attitude is disgusting and then the
owner [ __ ] wrote a novel like she
responded with a coal bunch of crazy
[ __ ] so she confirmed how [ __ ] crazy
and mean she is pretty much but then so
like when I read the owners a response I
was like oh Jessica she must be like in
the right but then Jessica responded
back to Victoria so the owner is backing
up the hybrid technician the i broug
technician ever got a chance to even
chime in the owner is the eyebrow sorry
I didn't clarify that yeah so then
Jessica ends up responding to Veronica
victorious so Jessica was the reviewer
the review that I just read was from
Jessica the owner and the Braille
technician her name is Victoria and so
Victoria ends up responding to Jessica
in this super [ __ ] long-ass novel and
it gets so petty she's calling her ugly
and also she belly Jessica then pretty
much that's what I thought crazy ass
[ __ ]
yeah but she was ugly she can get her
brows done yet come on [ __ ] yeah and
then and she starts claiming that she
was on drugs and like all this [ __ ] like
Victoria just [ __ ] both crazy so then
I'm thinking oh just but then Jessica
goes in and responds a whole ass novel
to whatever Victoria said so then now
they both just sound crazy but pretty
much what Victoria is trying to say is
that
sukkah went to her brow studio as a spy
for a different route technician because
jessica is also a broad technician and
then it's like it's just [ __ ] crazy
they do that on Yelp they do today that
Jessica actually get her [ __ ] down by
her though
so Jessica claims she did and I should
ingest achill claims that she has a
venmo receipt or like proof yeah that
she paid Victoria for their services
services but then Victoria comes back
and says no you paid a deposit for your
your appointment which I thought was
kind of worried I've never heard of that
but anyway she gave a deposit and she's
like that's what the venmo thing is I
never worked on your brows you are lying
you're crazy and then Jessica ends up
providing these screenshots messy just
for some [ __ ] eyebrows get the [ __ ]
out of here
this Plus this is Victoria's response
rate
Jessica provides screenshots of text
messages that she ugly-ass [ __ ] with a
[ __ ] up nose job yes so Jessica's
claiming that this is Victoria punch you
ugly-ass [ __ ] with the [ __ ] up nose
job when I catch you I'm gonna punch you
right in your face and you've got a big
ass stomach that's why you can't sit up
straight you [ __ ] weirdo
I know where you work out of them when
your ugly ass son goes to school you
have no man you miss boom what [ __ ]
shaped like an apple pretty funny
jealous bum [ __ ] nobody wants you I got
a nice Thanksgiving surprise for your
ugly ass and then it continued Wow and
then just before you read these texts
[ __ ] shaped like an apple shaped like
an apple
Victoria ends up bringing in Jessica's
sister in the whole mix saying that
Jessica's sister also leaves negative
reviews and laughing my [ __ ] ass off
your sister is ugly as [ __ ] with those
tadpole bras and ugly face and a fat
bloated ass husband but there's no neck
tatted and that's my [ __ ] ass off
y'all [ __ ] it's sad and tell your
sister I said thanks she gave me what I
needed laughing my [ __ ] ass off you
lost it now you
Matt can't wait to send over your
low-life behavior to your son's school
and post it all over your building they
will all have a link where to see you're
mentally ill behavior you're such a
dummy you're look ugly lowlife with a
big stomach that can't even defend
itself
[ __ ] I'm bringing in Jessica's son into
all this thing because she was saying
like I know where your son goes to
school how do I get each other's numbers
well I'm assuming because of the
appointment thing oh that's what I'm
assuming and then this is this is when I
was like okay Jessica I got you back
anymore cuz look at her respond oh
[Music]
that's like a page from of my submitted
[ __ ] were they write really fast they
talk [ __ ] and write really fast cuz I
read this whole thing and it's a lot of
like repeating of the same thing
especially coming it was a two thread so
it's like an actual argument cuz you
know when people argue in person they
[ __ ] repeat themselves over and over
so that's what they did but text ya ano
they were doing the voice the voice
thing well you know what and they were
like doing it and it's like the reading
the text read it shaped like an apple
it's probably one of the best insults I
have heard this whole year had pull
eyebrows that's like a tadpole eyebrow
interesting too because like there's
just some things like it just it's not
proper etiquette when it comes to these
things and it does happen to like it
happened with trips to where there was a
competitor Sophos or a person that
actually had employees leave bad reviews
and we brought it up with you up and
they took it down because we actually
have camera footage with their [ __ ]
like shirt logo and stuff oh that's
pretty [ __ ] bad you know like well
you know it's like [ __ ] like that and
they remove the the reviewers [ __ ] like
that people actually do that like
competitive like competitive businesses
which is pretty stupid that's what I
don't trust a lot of reviews on Yelp
because there are competitors that
[ __ ] send spies over [ __ ] it up and
like what [ __ ] have to realize -
there's no point in you doing that just
because of one business does well it
doesn't mean it's gonna shut you down
because whatever that fills up it'll
spill over and both you guys will
prosper together
just tells me that they have low
confidence and they [ __ ] suck yeah
like you do your thing and the other
people you got destroy other people's
businesses for and so now Victoria
saying that she has contacted the police
because she's claiming that Jessica is
very mentally ill so I'm going back to
the whole fact that Jessica said that
she showed up early and that Victoria
told her relief yeah
Victoria is claiming that she showed up
almost an hour early she's like who does
that
she even said that she sent a
confirmation telling her not to come
more than five minutes early why would
you show it early love a little and
she's like putting all this in caps and
like just it comes up so childish and so
petty and it's like you're so not
professional dude like no matter whether
you're in the wrong or the right like I
kind of want to go to that salon just
like I talked to Victoria and just get
all the cheese mat like firsthand
because she tells it good there's like
ways to respond to like you know do it
in private messaging and if that person
is being ridiculous I clearly you know
that your suspicions are confirmed about
what that person is doing and that's
when you could take it up with you if
not then you can leave a public comment
talking about the dispute and say like
hey I'm sorry this is what dude this is
way better we're hearing is she not that
good of a [ __ ] talker did you call her
fruit - well a bomb shaped like an apple
you pumpkin [ __ ] I don't like being
in the mix I like being like on the
sidelines like it's like a battle rap
yeah it's like Apple you're a [ __ ]
pear-shaped [ __ ] you know it's funny
cuz I was doing your eyebrows your mouth
was opening to have me to smell like
dick so just let you know obviously you
uh-huh that's right but you know she
kept it clean she kept it clean but then
like she would use fruits or like oh
you're gonna for some reason it sounded
very g-rated cuz she was talking about
Thanksgiving and I was like I would get
you something for Thanksgiving it's like
that's all nice [ __ ] living like a
fresh cooked turkey with your [ __ ]
coupled up newspaper belly [ __ ] what
you got stuffing in your belly
so Jessica she ended up posting a
screenshot of a conversation that she
had with another Yelp reviewer of
Victoria are they all getting all their
numbers in [ __ ]
through Yelp oh so this is so I'm
Jessica she'll be victorious so Jessica
writes to his girl named Kelly hi I've
been revived awful threatening messages
from browse by Victoria did she did she
do the same to you Jessica and then
Kelly write back hi Jessica yes I did
she also stalked me on Instagram she is
nuts did you ever leave her a bad review
yes she has resorted to threatening my
son at his school I have contacted the
authorities would you be able to go to
the detectives do you have her texts or
emails I never in my life have been
treated this way this girl has done this
to numerous others women Jessica and she
leaves her phone number so that kind of
like validated someone else is also
saying like yeah Victoria is [ __ ]
crazy she even stalked my Instagram just
cuz I looked her bad review so it's hard
for people like you know what this means
right girl should shouldn't start
businesses why did I picture a white
girl with corn rolls yeah I pictured
like a very sassy like her eyebrows are
pretty good though yeah she's the owner
and this is Jessica well it looks like a
white version of her it's crazy
no you know what this really means right
people in New York are stressed out oh
this is a New York right so they got
that [ __ ] New York sass they're just
so stressed stop also too when you own a
business sometimes it's just not about
being right or wrong it's about being
good service and service is always what
counts in cities just obsessing
[Laughter]
[Music]
Oh